people of the internet's retroreckon
tour here and in today's video we'll be
talking about how
i would keep the hype alive for hogwarts
legacy because right now
i gotta be honest guys it feels like it
could be
dying a little bit of course we didn't
get any news at this year's e3 or the
summer game fest and i admit it's easy
for us as youtubers and fans to sit back
and critique what should have been done
or what might have been done but it's
not always so
simple on the other side today i want to
put my money where my mouth is so to
speak and actually try
and think through what the best
marketing tactics would be for a big
game like this
should they be saying anything at all
right now should they be quiet right now
should they be
doing an all-out marketing blitz we're
gonna talk about all of that here
today okay so part one here marketing
background i do have a little bit of
experience in
marketing and communications with a
major company and also have a graduate
degree
in the field now it's not what i work on
now and i don't want you to think i have
some huge
extensive background but i have studied
it and know a little bit about it here
now first off here one thing i can tell
you is that the marketing team is almost
certainly completely separate from those
who are actually working on the game
you see there's this common critique
that i see among fans whenever you have
one fan who's saying man i really want
to see more a screenshot or
a new trailer or i want to see gameplay
whatever it may be a very popular retort
that i see to that is that another fan
will come in and say
guys you're crazy we can't rush
avalanche what are you doing we don't
want another cyberpunk
seriously if i have to see that one more
time i might scream
well i agree we should not rush the
development those comments don't quite
make sense in this context
as i mentioned the folks in charge of
promoting this game probably don't work
on the game itself instead you have your
advertising agencies you have pr
firms and wb as the publisher for the
game almost certainly has some folks in
these roles within their own company
avalanche probably even has folks who
work on these tasks
specifically as well but these are not
your game designers or coders or writers
we're in a completely different area
here so if we're talking about
getting a few screenshots tweeting out
information advertising that sort of
thing it's not going to be taking away
time from game development except for
one
little issue that we'll talk about here
in a bit but for the most part this is
completely separate so you guys don't
have to worry whenever someone says they
want to see more of the game that
doesn't mean they want avalanche to rush
and put it out tomorrow it
just means we want to see more that's it
now how these things will usually work
is the folks in charge at wb will set up
a
marketing plan for the game they'll
decide how much money they're going to
put into promoting the title and then
they'll task the marketing team with
going out and making it happen
the folks in marketing will have regular
meetings and conversations with those
actually making the game to get an idea
of their progress and also
of course so they know what's in the
game after all if they're going to mark
the title they'll need to know how it
plays the overall story
etc plus those folks on the inside will
have extensive access to research and
demographics about both the game the
target audience
things that i don't necessarily have
here so their marketing campaign should
end up being a lot better and more
targeted than what i'm able to put
together here
pressures on wb so in order to begin the
marketing campaign for
a game it's a good idea to know the
release date so we can kind of work
backward at least have a fairly narrow
release window
given that all we have right now is 2022
let's just
assume for the sake of our video here
today that hogwarts legacy will be
releasing around
july 2022 which would put it in the same
month as fantastic beasts three hitting
theaters
with that target month in mind that
gives us a full year of time for a
steady ramp up marketing campaign
and i think for a game this size roughly
a full year of steady planned out
promotion and tactics would be
ideal so for phase one of that plan i
would immediately start getting
more active on social media particularly
twitter and instagram
these could start out as weekly posts of
varying types some weeks maybe a new
screenshot or two other weeks may be a
random fact about the game and we could
even throw in polls here and there as
well
the challenge here is you obviously
don't want to bombard people with a
bunch of irrelevant tweets that no one
cares about but you do want to keep the
interest high and provide a steady
trickle of quality information and this
doesn't necessarily have to be
every single week for the next year but
i think some sort of consistent social
media presence would go a long way
toward keeping fans
engaged and excited and on the marketing
side of things it's completely
free there's literally no charge other
than what you're paying the marketing or
pr person to do this
it would only take a little bit of time
each week for someone to prepare and
send out the posts
even if you need to hit up the devs for
some screenshots that's something that's
not going to take a lot of time for them
to do
so if we start getting more active on
social media in july 2021
i would be sure to release a steady
stream of new screenshots throughout the
months of august and september maybe
showing off various creatures that we'll
encounter or even some locations that we
may visit
now with halloween being such a big
moment throughout the harry potter
series i think
october would be a unique opportunity to
reveal a little bit more about the
character creator and how it will work
in the game
considering this will almost certainly
happen at the opening of the game i
don't think anyone would be too worried
about having something like this
spoiled in fact it might be nice to get
an idea of how many options we'll have
and what the creator will be like so we
can start planning who we want to be
when the game releases
are we going to have beard options
avalanche i really need some strong
beard options in this game
when november hits this is our time to
really start teasing that full
gameplay reveal i'd ratchet up the
social media posts here and maybe even
have some sort of interactive scavenger
hunt or game for fans to figure out the
release date for the long time old
school harry potter fans you guys
remember how much we obsessed over jk
rowling's website the door
how could anyone forget that door and
now she actually revealed the title for
deathly hallows through that little
online game among
other things that she revealed to the
site if there's one thing you know for
sure about harry potter fans it's that
we love digging for clues and trying to
solve riddles and puzzles
december would put us at about seven
months out and considering this is also
the month for the game awards i think it
makes perfect sense to finally show a
brand new trailer here
with a specific focus on gameplay
ideally this would also be a great time
to announce the release date you could
possibly follow this up with another
playstation blog post similar to what
they did after the initial reveal
trailer now when it comes to the trailer
this is the point that would require
some work
on the side of the developers at
avalanche so in the opening we talked
about how
this is completely separate here we've
got our pr guys we've got our marketing
guys
they're focused on the promotion of the
game however to build something like
a trailer at that point you are going to
need some of those cinematics folks from
over at avalanche to help
create that trailer so at this point you
can make a pretty strong
argument that this would actually pull
people from working on the game to
create this trailer i think it's worth
it i think they have to have
another trailer i've actually heard
horror stories about devs prepping for
big trailers for e3 when they have
almost nothing ready to show
so this is the point where i hear you
when you say don't rush avalanche of
course you want to make sure that they
have ample time to work on their other
tasks but i think you also have to
consider the importance of
marketing and making a good trailer to
make sure this game gets
out to the public and so more people see
this from here we would ride the wave
of momentum from the trailer throughout
january and into the month of february
all while continuing our active presence
on social media
once we get into march we're now only
four months away
and this is the point i would look to
reveal a hogwarts legacy collector's
edition
i already made a separate video which
i'll link to in the card above about
specifically what i would like to see
as part of a hogwarts legacy collector's
edition and even if it doesn't have the
items i want i definitely think it would
be a
huge missed opportunity for this game
not to have some sort of special edition
with a few goodies in store for us die
hard fans for the month of april 2022
i'd try and get some sort of deep dive
interview with one of the developers of
the game and start doing more interviews
with various video game news sites and
youtube influencers
hey if anyone at avalanche or wb wants
to chat a bit feel free to reach out
just a few questions not too many that's
all i promise
as for the month of may i'd really try
and hone in on some cross promotion with
fantastic beasts 3.
this could be in the form of a special
tv advertisement that focuses on both
setting up plans to show the hogwarts
legacy trailer in the movie theater for
folks watching the movie
and maybe even throwing in a free
fantastic beasts movie ticket for anyone
who pre-orders the game
i think little things like that would go
a long way and it's a great opportunity
to cross promote between the two
properties
once june hits we're almost there and
this is when i'd really
ramp up on the online advertisements
both in the form of youtube and twitch
ads
as well as display and web banner ads on
some of the most popular harry potter
sites as well as video game sites and
that would take us
all the way up to the month of july
which in this fun little mock example
we're doing is the pretend release date
for the game woohoo
we finally made it guys if you all enjoy
this marketing plan hit that thumbs
up button before you go let wb know hey
i'd like to see something like this and
if not let me know down in the comments
what you would like to see instead
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon